this past weekend President Trump told
reporters he'll know if the Kim jong-un
meeting is going well by touch and feel
that's what he said
in other words Trump's lawyer is going
to have to pay Kim jung-ho in 130 when
you're a star they let you do it yeah
here's a weird one this is absolutely
true this was reported North Korean
leader Kim jong-un brought his own
toilet brought his own toilet to the
summit in Singapore
yes yeah when he saw the toilet
president Trump said oh so you're
planning to tweet too
[Applause]
while in singapore kim jeong-hoon took
this selfie never saw and see this
before check it out he took this selfie
isn't that cool and check out that guy
in the background who photo bombed him
that guy is now dead a tank of piranhas
I'm told that's what I think yeah and
everyone in his family in a ditch in
addition to a toilet he always travels
me to tank up around yeah let's go now
president Trump said that during the
North Korea summit he will not I repeat
not focus on human rights abuses yeah
yeah Trump said my marriage is no one's
business
[Applause]
good night you see the Tonys last night
anyone watch the Tonys well I didn't
know but some people did yeah last night
Robert De Niro I guess he he's what
they're all talking about Robert De Niro
bashed President Trump at at the Tony
Awards yeah and I was thinking I was
thinking I was thinking that Tony's I'm
sorry but I'd be much more impressed
with De Niro if he did that at the
Country Music Awards yeah a little easy
at the time right and a NASCAR event
yeah yeah yeah yeah pull that in
front of Reba McEntire see what happens
I just want to mention this has another
due than anything but it was a story in
the news today there's a Japanese pop
band Japanese pop in whose members are
all over 80 years old every single one
is over 80 years old yeah yeah the band
is known for their number one hit song
where am i what's their number two song
Andy I'm cold I'm cold I think number
three is don't slam that door yeah
you